head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
here's the big news ladies and gentlemen
in a tweet from Kaylee mcinany looks
like Biden's visit to Florida had an
inverse effect quote the number of
Republicans voting in Miami-Dade County
a historically blue stronghold surpassed
Democrats on Wednesday just one day
after President Joe Biden visited the
county 2 campaign I gotta be honest it
really does sound like Biden showed up
and they all were like you want us to
vote for what no no no not happening
here's where it gets crazy
the data shows that Republicans are
leading in the early vote
now that's crazy because the early votes
always Democrat right now in Miami-Dade
early voting numbers 27 Republican 21
Democrat that means come election day
Miami-Dade County a blue City
historically Democrat stronghold may
actually vote Republican they may vote
for Ron DeSantis this is massive so when
everyone keeps saying Red Wave I'm like
okay
it's a dire sign they say for the
Democrats it sounds really really great
but ain't nothing gonna happen unless
you go out and vote and get your friends
to go vote and I'll put it this way if
you think you're going to win so you're
gonna do anything you will lose hands
down it'll happen
but if you rally everybody you know and
you go vote you could possibly win in
such a tremendous way the defeat would
be so crushing that no one would dare
run under the Democrat ticket ever again
because their policies are insane or at
the very least there would need to be a
very hard reformation and we'd see the
next two years of Democrats begging for
forgiveness because the policies they're
proposing are just they're just nuts
Republicans at the very least are
talking about gas prices so what do you
think's going on how do you feel about
this Miami stuff you're a Florida guy
right I love Florida I spend a lot of
time in Miami there's also a lot of
Cubans there a lot of Cubans like myself
who just came from communist regimes and
understand you know yeah Cubans like me
who went through a Communist Regime
right oh I see there were commas in that
sentence yeah right there were commas
that doesn't matter uh but but a lot of
people there realize you know especially
through the lockdowns especially with
how Florida handled covid that you know
you have to of course represent larger
ideas that represent you and it's it's
pretty clear that there was a party that
wants more lockdowns that wants more
restrictions that wants more taxes and
financially I think we're let's just be
honest here in a bit of a pickle I think
a lot of people in Miami realize that it
is fast it is booming there's a lot of
things going on but at the same time it
is a major city and I think a lot of
people are also feeling the Havoc of the
major failed policies by the Biden
Administration in Miami that's crazy
yeah I feel like if I was a liberal who
was running I wouldn't want Biden to
come down to campaign with me because
Biden's been so bad he's been such a
failure I think most people not just in
Florida but all over the country are
probably like oh my gosh everything was
great under Trump and now everything's
horrible under Biden so if I was a
Democrat running I would say here's what
I'm going to do different maybe from
both maybe this is like a new idea have
a new plan don't associate yourself with
Biden just do your separate campaigns
you're right there have been many
Democrats who have told them do not send
Joe Biden here like we can maybe win if
he doesn't show up and then he shows it
to Miami and look what happens a day
later Republicans overtake Democrats I
got I got to say I'm willing to bet
people went out saw him and then went no
way not happening and then immediately
went we're like I'm voting Republican
were there poll numbers before his
speech or yeah I mean these are early
vote numbers that's what ABC is
reporting before he came Democrats were
leading in the early vote after he comes
a day later Republicans jump up there's
that like you know there's that reality
of like being in the presence of a rock
star when you go to a show when you're
actually there near them you start to
Vibe you like feel it and you start to
get into it because you're in the
presence of I imagine it works in the
opposite direction as well when you have
someone like Joe Biden who is maybe has
anti-charisma I don't know it's like
Trump whenever he endorses candidates
they are immediately the person who gets
a nomination he helps them win whereas
Biden he goes towards a candidate
they're like oh my gosh now my campaign
is ruined please don't associate with me
and then plus it's like if you think
about it when Trump ran in 2016 then he
runs in 2020 his 2020 slogans were like
oh look here are all the great things
that happened since then let's have more
greatness more winning we're never tired
of winning but with Biden it's like you
can't say that because things have been
so bad so you basically have to say
um well I guess no real message like oh
Ukraine's the problem this is the
problem we can't really have any excuse
here we did have a little success but
like not really so there's no real
message of what they're gonna do there
is Maga Republicans are bad Maga
Republicans are evil that's what Joe
Biden did the other night he's like you
know these these these violence violence
got to stop and he's saying all this
nonsense about election deniers and I'm
like dude I'm glad he came out and said
all that stuff about how election
denying is wrong because when the
Republicans win in a red great flood to
come you know we'll get all the results
in on the ninth or whatever then we can
tell all of the Democrats who are
whining and crying about it hey hey no
election denying you know Biden says so
hey hey Biden said no election denying
and then what are they going to say
they're gonna they're still gonna deny
it yeah we'll see Abrams she's gonna of
course come out crying she's already she
was the first election denier she was
the one who said it was stolen last time
so I don't know what her plan is because
I think she's going to lose this time so
she's probably gonna say it was stolen
again which one does she say was stolen
like she runs for governor of Georgia
the polling is showing that she's gonna
lose and last time she ran she also lost
but kept saying it was stolen well the
Atlantic called her a superstar loser
I'm I'm really impressed the Atlantic
said this Democrats keep falling for
Superstar losers there's never been a
better time to lose an election okay I'm
just going to point out that when the
Atlantic is calling your candidates
losers before the election
I have to wonder is this like the media
is conspiring to make Republicans think
they're going to win so that they don't
turn out or something because turnout's
already really good for Republicans but
maybe this is what I was just saying
if every single person
who is independent and just hates the
Democrats sick of their BS and their
policies and every single conservative
went out and voted and voted against
Democrats be it Republican or whatever
the Democrats would lose so horribly
that they would be forced to reflect all
these big packs they'd come in and be
like why are we losing and then
someone's gonna be like I don't know
maybe it was the child's sex changes in
the Eight dollar gas and they'll go okay
and they're gonna have to have a
reckoning and it's gonna force them to
course correct and get off of this
garbage so you're saying the Dylan
Mulvaney endorsement is not going to
help them I'm pretty sure that something
like that actually hurt them
substantially and that's why Colbert
came out and lied about that guy's story
so it was a guy from Dearborn Michigan
who told Tudor Dixon that when he saw
the explicit books in the kids school he
got really angry and the Democrats
ignore it or or support it so he's
voting Republican and then Colbert's
like never happened she made it up
that's a fake story because he knows
that if the American people actually
knew about books like this one that
Ian's got right here genderqueer they
they'd freak out and the only reason
parents did freak out is because of the
with the lockdown all the parents were
watching their kids in Zoom class
hearing the teacher talk about this
stuff and pull these books yeah we saw
what happened in Loudoun County not far
away from here that even threatened and
scared to the FBI to the point where
they said that they're going to be
sending resources to investigate parents
that show up at teacher parent
conferences I mean this is the absurdity
of this Administration obviously they
have had failed policy after failed
policy after failed policies but these
are not failed policies these are
policies that I think a lot of people
are rushing through through the dead
vessel that is the Biden puppet
Administration and when you look at
these these policies they're not popular
they screw everyone over no one likes
them but at the end of the day they do
serve a purpose and there are a lot of
Corporations a lot of big banks that are
benefiting off of them but everyone else
is screwed now if only you know the
tally ban the drug traffickers and the
Ukrainian government could vote maybe
then we would have a totally different
political perspective but uh we we don't
have that here in the United States we
have a pushback against what I see is
the great reset I just want to read this
one super chat I am says Red Wave is
such a generic term I've decri I decree
it to be called The Scarlet let's surge
that's pretty good the Crimson Crush
I think it's dangerous to vote against
people in general like saying this
administration's so bad that I will vote
for the other thing because I think
that's what happened with the Nazis is
it was so bad after World War one that
people just wanted something different
so they grabbed the not the most
charismatic different one the Nazi eye I
I I agree to a certain extent I really
don't like the idea of voting against
Democrats or like voting against a
politician and so you know I sympathize
with what Dave Smith was saying that you
know you can't keep voting for the for
the lesser of two evils but my view
right now is like we're in the midterms
we're not voting for our president we're
looking at our our congressional
candidates and local Representatives
they like these are people that you can
go and talk to the local level these are
not the lesser of two evils often yeah
sometimes but but there's only a few
populist candidates there's some that
represent the will of the people but the
other Republicans are like I'll just do
what the Democrats are doing but just 10
years from now but that's why the
primaries were so important sorry but
cut you off oh no I was just going to
say disagree with you and that I think
that that's also how we defeated Hitler
because we had to Ally with Stalin
because Hitler was such a great threat
so sometimes you have to go with the
lesser of two evils in order to take on
the greater evil in the end so I do feel
like it's it's okay if Americans say oh
my gosh my life sucks like Biden is so
bad this like this economy is so bad I
can't keep living like this to vote for
someone new because a lot of the new
candidates they might not know them they
might say I'm not sure if I agree with
everything they say but I know I agree
with this and then try it and then you
know see what happens in 2024. we just
saw the libertarian candidate in Arizona
drop out and endorse Masters and so you
know Libertarians and conservatives have
some overlap but not a whole lot and as
with the mesis caucus now there's some
when it comes to like cultural issues so
there's actually kind of a big deal I
remember I was uh I remember who told me
this there was some Republicans were
saying the conservatives in like 2018
they were like or they're saying some
conservatives had Libertarians need to
just you know sit down and vote
Republican and then I'm just thinking
like dude Libertarians don't like your
policies like they they're not you in a
different party they genuinely don't
but now the threat from Democrats is so
great to actually see the libertarian be
like you know actually I would rather
have this guy because he at least has
some advancement in the cause of Freedom
as at least relative to the Democrats
who are authoritarian cultists well
there is some overlap right it's not
like it's just uh black and white here
because when it comes to the Second
Amendment when it comes to the first
amendment when it comes to the populist
individuals coming forward representing
those ideas in the battlefield of ideas
yes they absolutely do do deserve
support and there are a lot of
neoconservatives a lot of back crazy-ish
insane individuals inside of the
Republican party that are way worse than
some of the staunchest Liberals in our
party establishment that do create
massive amount of damage to our current
way of life to our freedoms and those
individuals do need to be called out so
a lot of the Libertarians are kind of
taking their popcorn and watching this
larger fight unfold within the
Republican party oh thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time